but before we begin I would like to ask
you all to bring out your cell phones
and make sure that they are turned off
thank you for your cooperation now let
me introduce Professor urban Lee and all
share of the Nobel Committee and
professor at the Department of cell and
molecular biology here at Karolinska
Institutet and professor Lee and all
will introduce the Nobel laureates and
give the motivation for the price thank
you the laureates distinguished guests
friends and colleagues I'm privileged
and honored to stand here today to
introduce the two Nobel laureates in
Physiology or medicine 2012 dr. John
garden and Shinya Yamanaka together
these two scientists have fundamentally
changed our review of the cellular
differentiation process and how we view
two specialized cells in our bodies
they've shown that the differentiated
cells state was not caused in stone but
that a dormant potential rejuvenation
could in fact be unchained in these
cells this is not only made us view
cells in the new light but also open new
avenues to gain insights into disease
and in the future to improve diagnosis
and hopefully develop new therapies to
either two incurable diseases the
achievements also provide a prime
example of our fundamental discoveries
rooted in basic science can profoundly
impact on or attempting to say
rejuvenate many areas of medical
research to put their discoveries in
context let us briefly revisit how we
came to learn about differentiated cells
the journey from a fertilized egg to an
adult individual has always fascinated
mankind
and an earlier count on developmental
processes date back to Aristotle us when
he temporarily left philosophy to go to
the Greek island of Lesbos and together
with T of Rastus ponder on botany
zoology and generally on the wonders of
life for a long time then progress was
more limited but with the advent of the
first microscopes in the 1600s
this allowed objects in the size of a
cell actually to be observed and Robert
Hooke one of the pioneers he looked at a
section cut out from piece of cork and
you observed structures that he thought
resembled miniature versions of amongst
chamber and hence he called these
structures cells and the modern cell
theory and the concept that a cell is
the building block of all living forms
that was established in eighteen
hundreds by scientists like Theodor
Schwann matthias schleiden and rudolf
virchow and as histology evolved and
microscopes and staining techniques got
better it gradually became clear that
our bodies contained many different
types of specialized cells each with a
unique morphology and here Ramon or
Kyle's beautiful drawings of cells in
the nervous system comes mind in the
light of this the notion that a
differentiated cell was an endpoint the
final stop on a developmental journey
grew stronger and this notion was
reinforced in the early days of selling
molecular biology but at the different
cell types not only looked different
they also were endowed with different
compositions of proteins and later on
also RNAs
furthermore with the discovery of mobile
genetic elements by Barbara McClintock
it's inconceivable that a genetic
material in the cell would be
irreversibly altered during cellular
differentiation there were also entropy
based models often portrayed as a
mountain landscape where the
differentiated cell stage was conceived
to be the most energetically stable
state and the differentiated cells would
peacefully be resting in the mountain
valleys put shortly the dogma was
building that the differentiated
else could not be persuaded to make a
round trip back to their original
immature state and such was the scene
when a John John Gurdon took on this
question discouraged early on by a
teacher to venture into science but
equipped with a sharp intellect
curiosity and I've been told an aptitude
for doing things in a small scale such
as building three mastered sailing ships
in walnut shells John Gurdon asked if a
differentiated cell nucleus could
restart development if it was placed in
the right environment they enucleated
egg cell and this work carried out in
the Frog Xenopus laevis began in the
life late 1950s and culminated in the
landmark publication in 1962 and this
discovery really ran counter to the
prevailing view that cell the cell
differentiation state was irreversible
but John Gordon was right and based on
his findings somatic cell nuclear
transfer has since been expanded also to
mammals notably in the form of Dolly the
sheep John Gurdon originally trained
would make a fish bear at the University
of Oxford where he received the PhD in
1960 after stay at Caltech from 1960 to
1963 he returned to Oxford to then later
moved to Cambridge University in 1972
from 1989 and onwards has been with a an
institute in Cambridge that since 2004
carries his name the Gurdon Institute
John Gurdon has received numerous awards
including the Wolf Prize in 1989 and the
Lasker medical research award in 2009 he
was elected fellow of the Royal Society
in 1971 and knighted in 1995 such would
rightfully be Sir John and with this as
a background please join me in welcoming
John Gurdon who will present his Nobel
lecture under the title the egg and the
nucleus a battle for supremacy John
should be alright Julian so first let me
thank Aban lindahl for his very fun
introduction and then say that this is
of course a very special occasion for me
and I mean or masti grateful to the
committee for Physiology and medicine
for this unique and immense privilege of
finding myself here today so I've chosen
to use this title for my talk because I
think the interaction between ergo
nucleus leading eventually to
reprogramming can really be summarized
as a battle between the egg and the
nucleus and at the moment I would say
the egg is doing very well but the
nucleus is slightly better and we need
to realize the full potential we need to
give the egg a little more help to try
and reduce the remarkable resistance of
the nucleus to being reprogrammed so
these are the subjects I will talk about
a bit of background explain the history
of the subject and then talk about the
egg how it is trying to reprogram a
nucleus and then talk about the nucleus
how it's trying to defend itself by
being reprogrammed and finally a few
words about prospects so I always think
one should start with a question and in
my case the question was all this time
ago whether all cells in the body have
the same sets of genes simple enough
question the originators of this whole
field were Robert Briggs and Thomas King
and they had great success in 1952
in succeeding for the first time in
transplanting a somatic nucleus to an
enucleated egg and getting normal
development from it however when they
tried to do the same experiment with the
nucleus of a more specialized cell or
actually just an embryo little bit later
on they found that there was no
successful normal development at all by
the time they took nuclei from the early
embryo
there was no success in obtaining normal
development so of course that led to the
idea that as cells differentiate they
might lose the capacity of their nucleus
to be reprogrammed might be lost
irreversibly well I then started work
after years later and was advised to
work with the South African Frog Xenopus
laevis is this one and we were I was
lucky at an early stage to get an
apparently normal frog from the nucleus
of a reasonably advanced embryo this is
the the first adult we had historically
it was a frog of good quality it lived
for about 20 years
and it had about 4000 offspring so it
was an indication that you can transform
the nucleus without generating any
adverse effects now a key step in this
history was my supervisor Michael fish
Berg who in a ingenious way discovered a
genetic marker which was essential for
proving that a transplanted nucleus on
its own will give rise to a normal
embryo and this new a new clear marker
involves counting nucleoli in a cell you
had to be able to distinguish between 1
and 2 and in these cells there is one
nuclei
in each of the nuclei representing as it
turned out the site of synthesis of
ribosomal RNA and in the wild-type which
was called a to nucleus stream there are
two nuclei in nearly all cells the one
nucleus Newton's was a deletion of
ribosomal genes mm-hmm and it was
immensely valuable so that one could
mark the nuclei being transplanted and
show that the resulting embryos always
had one nucleolus in our nuclei and
never had two so with this background
the examples work led like briggs and
king
the success rate went down the more
advanced were the embryos from which
nuclei were taken nevertheless even when
you took swimming larvae their cells to
a significant extent were able to
produce entirely normal
normal embryos and that then reopened
the question of whether as cells
differentiate their nuclei might still
be able to generate normal development
so looking again ahead a bit we started
using the intestine of a feeding larva
so it's intestine cells were functional
and in this case we could use the GFP
marker to mark these nuclei transplant
the nuclei to eggs and when you do that
you sometimes get normal embryos but
more often you get these partially
Bria's with normal cells at one end and
a complete failure of development at the
other end of the embryo now these
embryos will die however they die within
about a day however it's possible to
take these cells and re transplant
a nucleus from those into another set of
eggs many of which will then develop
normally without this making a defective
embryo it's also possible to take a few
of these cells which you may remember a
GFP marked and Transplant them as a
graft to a normal host embryo like this
you can see the the graft stuck onto the
normal embryo and when these developed
they can form normal entirely normal
embryos and all of these green cells
each one is a single muscle cell nicely
oriented orientated with respect to the
host cells which are do not carry the
marker they are black and it shows that
the functional muscle can readily be
derived from the nucleus of an intestine
cell so that was be the origin of much
of this work and when we summarize that
put that together we can add up the
success rate of the so called first
nuclear transfers and add to that
results obtained by the serial second
nuclear transfers and also include
grafts made in the way that I've
described and when you do that the
success rate with which you can obtain
for example functional muscle and nerve
from intestine is around 30% so that
says that the cytoplasm is pretty good
at redirecting the nucleus of a muscle
cell so that instead of continuing its
life is intestine ik and the cytoplasm
of the egg can switch it back to the
beginning of life and send it out in the
direction of muscle and nerve but at
this point this success rate of 30% also
means that 70% of the embryos do not
achieve that and so in terms of this
conflict or battle we would say the
nucleus on the whole is winning
cytoplasm does pretty well but but most
of the nuclei are unwilling to be
changed back to redirect their
differentiation so at this point I
should acknowledge the work of will
Moton Keith Campbell who in 1997 were
able to do nuclear transfers in in the
lam in in sheep an interesting question
of course is why there was a gap of some
40 years or so between the early frog
experiments and the sheep experiments
and the short answer is that the people
working with mammals mostly with mice
early on did not actually follow exactly
what was done with the frogs for some
reason they chose to use fertilized eggs
which were extremely difficult to deal
with and enrollment and keith campbell
chose to do exactly what had worked with
frogs and obtained these wonderful
results with sheep so in summary then
the results with the frog and mammals
are remarkably similar in each case you
get about a 30 percent success rate if
you take mammals reaching birth or
Xenopus reaching tempo stages and as you
take nuclear for more advanced stages
the success rate goes right down so
that's a measure again of this
resistance of the nuclei defending
themselves against the onslaught of the
egg trying to make them change direction
now I'll now refer to a remarkable
experiment of James Byrne who was a
student of mine but he didn't do this
work with us he did it later
so he took monkeys skin and eggs from
another monkey did the nuclear transfer
or cloning as it's called made the
embryonic stem cells brilliant discovery
by Martin Evans and was then able to
increase the cell number and add factors
to make these cells now turn into
beating heart
and if
impatient this will probably show the
beating heart cells from the monkey skin
it's a sheet of these thousands of cells
beating remarkably well in Indus these
cardiomyocytes because the problem is
when you transplant those cells to a
heart they do not end present technology
integrate well but that was a very
elegant demonstration of what can be
done now briefly let me mention this
phenomenon or epigenetic memory which in
effect shows that a transplanted nucleus
will very often remember where it came
from even though the egg is making its
switch fate now in this case one was
taking a muscle cell transplanting its
nucleus and make an embryo and then
separate the embryo into the future
neuroectodermal nerve and skin cells
take away the future muscle bit and
separate the ended on bit and rather
amazingly the future nerve and skin
cells or gut cells continue to express
muscle genes to a surprisingly large
extent start with muscle go through and
go into the nerve lineage but
nevertheless those cells remember
somehow that they came from muscle we
had reason to think this might have to
do with a particular protein called
histone h3 point 3 and so we were able
to use a mutation in that gene to
essentially compete out the normal
histone h3 point 3 which is present in
the egg and show that when you did this
you eliminated this memory sort of being
50% also it went down to just a few
percent so that indicated that histone
h3 point 3 is one of the factors the
eggs you eggs use to increase
transcription and when you transplant a
nucleus that is already committed to one
fate the egg enforces continuation of
that expression which makes it very hard
to reprogram it so this is another
reflection of the amazing defense that
the nucleus of a specialized cell will
put up as it were to resist the
reprogramming activities of the egg so
in summary then the epigenetic memory as
we call it is reflects the activity of
this variant histone 83.3 which promotes
transcription of active genes and the
egg cytoplasm can reverse that but only
with about fifty thirty to fifty percent
efficiency so that then makes one turn
to how one can start to analyze this
conflict of interest a bit further and
I'm now going to talk about these cells
called first meiotic prophase our sites
which are the progenitors of the egg now
this simplifies the analysis to a
considerable extent because in the
experiments that I've just been talking
about you transplant a nucleus and you
get an embryo but before that happens
there are numerous cell divisions and
replications before the embryo can form
an adult frog and this is where the
where the reprogramming happens where
the egg is switching the nucleus back
now that complicates analysis very
considerably because when this happens
there is incomplete DNA replication and
this damages the somatic nuclei so that
many of them are no longer capable of
following normal development to overcome
that one can use these egg progenitors
which we call oo sites they contain a
large object called the germinal vesicle
and one can inject multiple nuclei into
this and this our site will continue
life it has no DNA no DNA
location occurs but intense
transcription and after a couple of days
or so these nuclei have now switched
they have now been reversed rejuvenated
and made to express embryo genes so you
don't get new cells but you've undone a
large part of the reversal process we
can understand this by realizing that
the egg progenitor or our site starts
life as a germ cell and then it
gradually forms the mature our site or
egg during this time the it's nucleus
can builds up a large reserve of these
reprogramming factors and only when the
our site eventually becomes an egg in
what seems like a flesh just a moment
the egg will form and will be fertilized
normally make cells and already you
start getting different cell types the
red blue and yellow so the other site is
preparing itself for a long period of
time like a hundred days building up
these reprogramming factors ready so
that when fertilization or nuclear
transfer happens it can immediately
embarked on normal development that's
why the our site is such a valuable
source of these reprogramming factors
the other site looks like this for the
Frog it's very big cell about a
millimeter in diameter and the its
nucleus the germinal vesicle is also
very large and the germinal vesicle
contains this reserve of reprogramming
components indicated in red and these
are distributed to the egg when the
oversight changes into an egg and then
to the embryo and they are necessary for
normal development so these are the key
reprogramming factors that are needed to
switch the somatic cell backwards in
development and if you look at gene
expression this works fine so here are
these nuclei which are adult nuclei and
no more ones work fine if you use
rapidly dividing cells like HeLa within
a day they have already started
expressing the key pluripotency factors
which we'll hear more about later on the
other hand when you use nuclear
specialized cells like Mouse Imus they
are significantly resistant they resist
the programming factors of the OA site
so this system enables us to begin to
analyze what is really happening so this
led to the oversight transcription
assays I call it and the major features
of this turning out to be very useful is
that Yukon transplants many nuclei
several hundred makes analyses easier
the new transcripts the pluripotency
gene transcripts are accumulate nicely
with time most notably the genes that
are being activated undergo recurrent
transcription continually many hundred
times a day and that cannot be done in
other systems and lastly the these
injections into our site show this
resistance or defense that were
interested in so now I turn to the
transcriptional activation in other
words what is it that the egg is doing
that is somehow able to a fair extent to
rejuvenate a dot nuclei and send them
back to the beginning of development so
I see it as the egg attacking this
somatic nucleus trying to force it
backwards and so how does this happen in
normal life the sperm is a tiny cell and
after in in mammals it forms this
enormous male pronucleus it undergoes a
massive expansion because the egg forces
that and so indeed when you transplant
nuclei somatic nuclei that happens also
here are these few hundred transplanted
nuclei and in a short while they form
these balloons big vesicles with a huge
d condensation or opening up of the
genome said the genes are now accessible
to factors from the egg and part of this
process is seen by the uptake of special
molecules of the egg which in this
experiment have been marked in red and
we start by transplanting nuclei in
which the the adult type linka histones
are shown in green and when you follow
this process in time one can see that
the the green molecules disappear and
the oocytes own red molecules take over
to a remarkable extent almost all these
transplanted nuclei have taken up the
red special histone linker histone of
the our site the few that happened the
green ones are interesting there are
ones where when we transplanted a
nucleus by mistake we transplanted a
whole cell if you transplant a whole
cell nothing can get into it you have to
transplant the nucleus not the cell for
the eggs components to gain access to
that nucleus and this process happens
surprisingly quickly this is in in about
two or three hours this whole process
will happen and that's amazingly fast
for a somatic nucleus that might expect
to spend the rest of its life as a
specialized cell within this short time
it can be the whole reversal process can
begin
due to these special histones obtained
contained in the in the our site and
soon after that there's another
chromosomal protein called histone h3
point-three which we've mentioned also
invades the incoming nuclei and one can
now follow this in some detail
by looking at the different forms of RNA
polymerase which also enters these
nuclei as well so these are the
transplanted nuclei 24 hours and 48
hours of to transfer and even the
elongating polymerase 2 is
successful in gaining access to these
transplanted nuclei at the same time the
nuclei lose some of the components the
RNA polymerase brought in by the donor
nuclei disappears and the tata binding
protein of somatic cells disappears and
is replaced by the tata binding protein
of the oocytes so these are the switches
which are happening very quickly and
they arise largely because the these
components are so abundant in the other
site that they force their way into the
nucleus just by mass action such a huge
abundance they invade the nucleus and
fill it up with these components and all
these components are necessary for the
reprogramming here you can see that the
different forms of RNA polymerase 2
follow each other within a short time
and rush into the nucleus to start
transcribing the genes which have been
opened up by the special histone that we
just mentioned another interesting thing
is that the RNA polymerase which is
needed to read these genes transcribe
these genes has to come from the OE site
so you can do an experiment with alpha
amanitin which kills the oocytes
polymerase 2 and if you use nuclei which
are resistant of this drug they shown in
the blue are quite unable to be
reprogrammed or gene switched on but the
OA site polymerase is if it's killed
will not allow that normally it allows
it as shown by the substantial increase
in expression of this gene so an
important question is where does the
selectivity arise so why is it that the
a site or egg can switch some genes on
and others not and this depends entirely
on the cell type the the original state
of the genes and the nuclei being
introduced and it shows her that a gene
which is very easily activated called
sox2 transcription start site that gene
will take up the special histone that
Limor ace and it will be transcribed
well now globin genes are not able to be
reprogrammed by the other site they're
resistant to it they defend themselves
against this egg activities and
nevertheless they absorb they can't help
absorbing this special linker histone
which over everything which opens
everything up on the other hand are
completely unable to respond to the
polymerase and so they are not expressed
so it in a straights the actual level at
which the this resistance or defense is
operating it's you can open genes up but
the actual machinery needed to read the
genes cannot work if the nucleus from
the adult cell is exerting its defense
so it will not allow these OSI factors
to operate and so we can begin to put
together these events which are needed
for the site to have its reprogramming
activity and this is these are some of
them there's no doubt a few others but
it gives us an indication of how the our
site or egg attacks the somatic nucleus
by overloading it with these abundant
components which enter the nucleus and
try to reverse it try to get it to go
backwards in development it's quite
useful to know what these are because
they are necessary without them there
would be no rejuvenation or reversal and
these are some of the components which
are needed for this special process
so now we turn to resistance or as I
call it defense by the nucleus and I
would argue that this is in many ways
the most important part of the whole
process of reprogramming why is it that
the nucleus is able to defend itself
against this enormous influx of
components offered by thee by the egg
and in the work that will shortly hear
about the famous IPS work the success
rate of reversal is normally very low
originally it was maybe one in a
thousand or 10,000 cells so most cells
have an extraordinary defense resistance
to reprogramming and I would argue that
if we could really understand that we
could assist the egg or other components
in rejuvenating nuclei and make the
whole process of reprogramming
considerably more efficient so what are
what is the basis of this resistance how
do nuclei defend themselves against the
reprogramming components of the egg in
one case we know something about this
and you will know that in female mammals
one of the two x-chromosomes
has no gene activity the genes of all
repressed they call it X inactive now
this turns out to be true if you take
nuclei from adult cells like mouse
embryonic fibroblasts they make no
response even in three days through a
reprogramming by the egg on the other
hand
similarly inactive X chromosomes from
the epiblast it's an earlier stage of
embryos are very well reprogrammed so
the two states of this inactive X
illustrate the difference between them
and hence what it is tell us something
about the component that is responsible
for this resistant state of the adult
nuclei now the short answer to this is
that it's been possible to identify this
component and it's called macro h-2a and
you can do experiments where you
eliminate that resistance factor and
when you do that you then turn on
pluripotency jeans or tan socks even in
the adult cells very well so this macro
h-2a helps to explain helps to explain
the resistance to reprogramming it's one
of the molecules which has to be
eliminated from nuclei to enable them to
be reprogrammed so in conclusion this
macro h2 is a good example of a molecule
that marks embryonic differentiation and
it acts as a epigenetic resistance
factor to nuclear reprogramming so that
leads us to now ask well what is what
kind of reprogramming is this do do we
see most genes in the genome being
reprogrammed or is that a rare and
specialized situation and when you
analyze all the genes in the genome you
find that the reprogramming or gene
selection 48 hours after nuclear answer
is highly selective so we can see that
genes which were often the donor nuclei
shown her low level or nil level of
expression but half of them just stay
off a few more were expressed to the
high rate and they stay on after nuclear
transfer and a few others when they're
after nuclear transfer they go from an
odd state to an off stage and a smaller
number less than 10% are actually
activated and those are the include the
pluripotency genes so it means that the
our site is not making a universal
activation of all genes it's quite
selective it will choose the kind of
genes it wants to be to be reactivated a
useful guide to the level at which this
reprogramming happens so in conclusion
the resistance or defense
or the nucleus is both gene-specific and
cell type-specific so there are two ways
forward at this point one is to start
analyzing the chromatin the molecules
that sit on genes and control their
activity and we'll talk about that first
so the way forward here is to change
these modifications genes have histones
and the histones have components on them
which regulate the expression of the
genes and so it's possible to inject
messenger rna's on on first and then you
transplant nucleon the second day and
then re isolate the transplanting nuclei
on day three and analyze what has
happened and when you overexpress
by message injection these different D
methylases or ubiquity ubiquitin raises
it has a substantial effect it's
possible to rarely remove these
components on the transplanted nuclei
and so see what effect they have and
this shows that this is quite effective
so normally you have high level of
methylation on these nuclei if you
overexpress the d methylase you
essentially remove all those so that's a
good way of changing these components
and hence determining what effect they
have as a matter of fact he takes me
back to one of my few experiments that I
really found worked amazingly well when
I a long time ago I wanted to try
injecting messenger RNA into eggs and
it's a proper a project which would
never have had any grant support at all
because it was known that if you take
eggs they are full or ribonuclease
absolutely stuffed full and if you add
right the nucleus to message it destroys
it immediately nevertheless it was the
kind of thing you think well we better
just try it
so we injected this precious message
which had been exhaustively purified by
people into the egg and
amazingly it worked perfectly so why
should that be and I suppose the lesson
you learn is that when you inject
something into an egg you do it almost
no damage at all you don't break open
all these nucleus containing components
and message injection has turned out to
be an extraordinarily useful technique
and I reflect on the fact that if I had
not had just enough funding to try it
anyway the extremity never have been
done and so how lucky it is when you
sometimes have a little bit of extra
cash to try something a little little
exotic so when you do these experiments
though they are quite effective you can
see that here we have the
heterochromatin one which is a nuclei
when you demethylate the lice in it they
completely disappear and as a control
this doesn't work with another
particular form of heterochromatin one
and this this approach is proving useful
because it's now we've begun to identify
some of the components that actually
create resistance and there's a
particular enzyme called d ubiquity
neighs which takes the ubiquitin away
from histones and you can see that when
you do this at time zero there is no
increase in gene activity two days later
it's very strongly activated and that
doesn't work if you use D mythili's so
we're beginning to identify those
components on the chromosomal proteins
that confer resistance or defense on the
nuclei and I'm sure there's a great deal
of more work to be done in this area but
it's one way forward and it's some
really only possible to do that if you
have these very favorable cells which
can be injected with almost anything you
like
so that begins to answer this question
but it doesn't entirely answer the whole
problem because it turns out that even
if you remove almost all proteins
from a nucleus from the chromosomes from
nucleus nevertheless the nucleus still
has defense so that's rather amazing and
one would say well in that case how sure
are you that this defense isn't
something like the methylation of DNA
well known to prevent genes being
reprogrammed and that's easily disproved
in many cases because you can remove all
of the proteins from a nucleus every
single one but leaving of course the
methylation of DNA and when you do that
the the defense disappears so you've
taken something away which was creating
this defense so what could that be
and the problem then is to find a way of
removing components progressively from a
nucleus while you can still keep it
alive enough to be transplanted and this
was done finally by finding a way of
wrapping the nuclei in a kind of cage so
that you can take molecules away from
them and nevertheless they do not
explode and they can be injected and the
first obvious test here is to ask about
the non-coding RNA is that what it could
be that gives this defense what you can
do is to remove almost all of the RNA by
digesting it away down to about some
five orders of make a hundred thousand
times less RNA take it away wash it all
a Dornan a back and so the RNA is still
functional but so then you have RNA
depleted nuclei and when you do this you
find that it makes no difference so here
we are with opt for gene or Sox to gene
and you take away the RNA or you don't
you get exactly the same resistance to
reprogram it because the slow rate it
goes up so that told us that
conveniently you can more or less
eliminate all of the non-coding RNA as a
defense mechanism of the nucleus what
about proteins well you can remove
almost all the protein
by washing the new car in high salton in
triton and how they are almost all gone
and yet when you've done that you find
that all of the most obvious proteins
that could give defense to a nucleus and
as a list of them here have been removed
either completely or almost completely
nevertheless the resistance persists
this this bar shows of unlike normal ear
cells which respond very well these ones
don't and so there is something sticking
to those genes which we don't know about
and which constitutes the ultimate level
of defense against reprogramming and
that's the direction which this work is
now taking so I'll leave that point
there and in a way summarize the the
point of this talk which is to say the
egg is designed to transform the sperm
which normally enters it at
fertilization into an embryo active
nucleus and the egg is amazingly good at
that it does it in 99% of cases the egg
will transform this minut completely
switched off sperm into complete
activity so that's what the egg is
specially designed to do and it's pretty
good at doing it on the other hand it
has a struggle when you give it the
nucleus of a specialized cell it it does
a pretty good job about 30 percent
success rate but it can't do can't do
the job completely on the other hand the
nucleus of a specialized cell is
designed for different purpose it's
designed to keep everything very stable
and you will know that we don't have
brain cells in our liver or we don't
have skin cells in our muscle so once
cells embark on a pathway they remain
very stable and that's really why the
nucleus builds up this defense against
change of course if the defense is
completely broken down there's a problem
of cancer and other things so
the nucleus is designed to maintain its
pattern of expression and try to resist
any change now the way forward from
there will of course ultimately be I
think to identify nuclear defense
components remove them and try to
facilitate or make more efficient this
reversal or rejuvenation of the nucleus
back to an embryonic state but the that
will take time and I'm sure the more
immediate advance will be through these
brilliant methods that Shinya Yamanaka
has developed which we'll hear about
shortly so that's I think where that is
and as I say the prospect must be - for
us to try to defeat resistance and win
efficient cell replacement so I'll just
acknowledge the people who've been
helping me in this current work and I
would like to take the opportunity of
mentioning a number of those who
throughout my career have given enormous
help and worked with me Donald Brown was
one of my first colleagues and Ron Lasky
has been with me for something in one
way on another something like 35 years
helping and guiding all the way along
Doug Melton edit Roberta's Lawrence Korn
Marv Wiccans allen coleman Chris Graham
and John Nolan or all early colleagues
with me at the time the early
experiments were done and particularly
I'd like to thank two people who started
life as a technician when I had no no
colleagues no graduate students at all
had one technician and these are the two
ladies who used to relentlessly collect
eggs and ultraviolet irradiate them and
hand them to me for nuclear transfer and
it's a special pleasure that they are
with us here and the presentation today
has particularly centred on work done by
James Byrne and steena Simonson Recaro
and Astro and who are both from this
country thank you
1962 was a remarkable year sorry
not only for John Gordon's landmark
paper but the world also witnessed the
birth of Shinya Yamanaka and equipped
with an MD from Kobe University and in
PhD from Osaka City University
Shinya Yamanaka first considered a
career as an orthopedic surgeon but a
post doctor's day at the Gladstone
institutes in San Francisco open his
eyes for the world of Celle molecular
biology and after returning to Japan and
the narrow University he became
intrigued by stem cells and in
particular by embryonic stem cells that
were discovered by Martin Evans who's
sitting here in the audience today
because embryonic stem cells can
maintain their immature state and
pluripotency during extensive in-vitro
culturing and Shinya Yamanaka was
interested me interested in unraveling
the basis for how this pure potency was
retained and he made very important
discoveries and contributed to
disappearing the underpinning
transcriptional circuitry description
factory circuitry for example by cloning
the gene Nanog however even bolder more
courageous and far-reaching ideas were
entertained by Shinya Yamanaka would it
in fact be possible to reinstate
pluripotency in an intact fully
differentiated cell and at that time
this was considered a utopian dream by
most scientists or at least that that
would be a very complex road to come
even close to that goal but in 2006
after relocating to Kyoto University
Shinya Yamanaka published a paper that
spellbound the scientific community
introduction of only four transcription
factors could convert a differentiated
cell to what became known as the IPS
cell and in only six years this
remarkable discovery that the
differentiated state could be unlocked
and converted to IPS cells
that has really taken the scientific
world by storm and the technology is now
used in thousands of laboratories
worldwide including several at this
University and it's used to address
important questions for example to model
and understand diseases incompletely in
other ways Shinya Yamanaka received his
MD from Kobe University in 1987 and a
PhD from Osaka City University in 1993
his currently professor and director for
serie the center for IPS cell research
and application in Kyoto and also senior
investigator at the Gladstone institutes
in San Francisco Shinya Yamanaka has
received numerous awards including the
Lasker medical research award and the
Wolf Prize in 2009 he was elected member
of the National Academy of Sciences in
the United States in 2012 and with this
as a background please join me in
welcoming Shinya Yamanaka who will
present his nobel lecture under the
title induction of pluripotency by
defined factors pleased junior
well thank you very much professor Ivan
Lendl for your very kind introduction it
is a great great honor for me to be
selected as one of the laureates of the
Nobel Prize in Physiology or medicine
this year I am grateful to the Nobel
foundation and chlorine Institute for
her for having chosen me as one of
laureates actually on October 7th just
one day before the announcement I met
the president of Korean Institute
professor Warworld Harrington in Kyoto
she chaired a session which I attended
when I said goodbye to her after the
session I thought she winked at me
I was not sure but I'm sure now she did
so I feel especially honored to share
this award with Sajal garden because for
us a garden initiated the field the
field of nuclear reprogramming without
his similar work done around the year I
was born I could have never been here
today so thank you very much John and I
whispering a lot for your brilliant head
both inside and outside so in my talk
today I'd like to talk on three topics
first I'd like to introduce to you my
early days in science as a scientist
then I'd rather like to discuss about
the researchers of my own and by others
that led to the generation of IPS cells
by finally I learn like to discuss the
potential of IPS cells
so let me start with this topic my early
days in science I have to say I was
extremely lucky in two ways when I was a
graduate student and I was a
postdoctoral fellow the fast track was
that I had multiple opportunities to
observe totally unexpected results that
brought me to completely new projects
the other luck was that I was able to
work under two great mentors so in the
next few minutes I'd like to share with
you with my experiences when I was a
student and the postdoc so as you heard
from Professor endo I started my career
as an off-speed ik sergeant but within a
year or two I realized that I was not
talented at all in surgery I also
realized that even a talented surgeon
talented doctor cannot help very
patients suffering from intractable
diseases and injuries because of those
two reasons I decided to change my
career from a surgeon to a scientist I
entered a graduate school in Osaka City
University and I majored in pharmacology
I studied the regression of blood
pressure mainly in talks the mentor at
the time was dr. Kazuki Veera
so this is the very first experiment I
performed as a graduate student in Osaka
still University we knew that the
intervenors injection of the basal
active molecule freight rate activating
factor path into docks caused a transit
decrease in blood pressure transit
hypotension dr. Miura hypothesized that
this transit decrease in blood pressure
is mediated by another molecule from
boxin 80 so he asked me to prove his
hypothesis
the experiment was very simple i pre
treated dogs ways an inhibitor option
box and a tube if doctors dr. Mira's
hypothesis is correct this should be
that we this is what we should observe
so we shouldn't observe any decrease in
blood pressure if dr. Mira's hypothesis
is correct so this experiment was
supposed to be a very simple experiment
suitable for a beginner suitable for
failed sergeant
but but I observed was something totally
unexpected in the beginning it looks
like the from box on a 2 inhibitor
showed any effect so I observed a normal
pattern of hypotension just kind of
boring result but after a few minutes I
observed this kind of a very profound
and prolonged decrease in blood pressure
when I looked at this I got so excited
that I rushed into dr. Mira's office and
take him to the talk although this
result was totally against his
hypothesis dr. Muller got also very
excited so for the next for the
following two years I examined the
molecular not molecule have the
mechanisms of this unexpected result and
that began my thesis after 2 years so
then I decided to continue my training
as a scientist in the United States I
became a poster at grab some Institute
of cardiovascular diseases in San
Francisco my mentor at the time was dr.
Thomas hilarity this is dr. hilarities
hypothesis he was very interested in one
gene a public one which he thought
important in cholesterol regulation
hypothesized that forced expression of a
phobic one this gene in dipper with
lower plasma cholesterol level so by
using a public one he thought he may be
able to prevent atherosclerosis so he
asked me to prove his hypothesis by
making transgenic mice over expressing a
phobic one in dipper so I worked very
hard day and night and I was able to
generate transgenic mice expressing high
amount of a public one and not liberal
specific manner one day in early morning
a technician working with me rushed into
me she was taking taking care these mice
and she said something strange to me she
said Shinya your mice many opium eyes
are pregnant
but they're male so I hope confused so I
went to the animal facility to check the
mice and I found she was right
many of my mice both male and female
they looked like they're pregnant so I
father looked into that was going on and
I found this totally unexpected result
it does not babies
it was this huge dipper cancers so it
turned out that this gene a phobic one
is a very potent uncle
we can never use this in treating
Pasteur sclerosis it's via crime
so very naturally doctor in authority
got disappointed but I got very very
excited and in a sense to me writing got
also excited too he encouraged me to
continue working on this gym a public
one so I became only one researcher we
worked on liver cancer in grad so
Institute of cardiovascular diseases but
again doc tannerite kept encouraging me
kept helping me so I'm very very
grateful to him so again in a sense I
had two types of great teachers great
mentors in my early days as a scientist
the one great teacher is a real teacher
dr. Meara and Doc tonality who
encouraged them despite the results
which were against their own hypothesis
the other great teacher of mine was is
nature itself who gave me totally
unexpected results and who which or who
brought me the completely new project I
have been trying to be a good mentor as
dr. Meara and dr. Dain energy that I
found is very difficult
but I keep I do my best so let me move
on to the second topic of my talk today
I would like to discuss about researches
of myself and by others that were to IPS
cells
so my own research that led to IPS cells
has studied from this unexpected result
from this unexpected liver cancer
actually young Boram is here with me he
is also a postdoc opto minerality so in
a snow samo is unexpected result so I
try to understand the cause of this
unexpected cancer clearance and I was
able to identify one gene which I one
new gene which I designated not one
novel a phobic one target number one
very straightforward name so fo great
one is an enzyme I identified not one as
a new substrate new target of a big one
and from its sequence I predicted that a
not one function as a tumor suppressor
gene and not one I thought not one is
responsible for the tumor for the cancer
I observed in April back one transient
mice
so I generated knockout mice and also
knockout year cells to prove my own
hypothesis but here again
I obtained totally unexpected result it
turned out that not one is essential for
prepotency of embryonic stem cells ESL's
while I was working on that one I had to
go back to Japan I really wanted to stay
at grad so I really wanted to stay in
the standing in the United States but
because of various issues I had to go
back to Japan but before talking about
my life in Japan let me discuss about
embryonic stem cells as all you know
embryonic stem cells ES cells are first
derived from mouse embryos in 1981 by
doctors Sir Martin Evans and also by dr.
Gail Martin
ES cells have two important properties
the first one is the rapid proliferation
is there a motor in
um oh my god I I promise I didn't do
this by hell purpose immortality
the other important I'm sorry for
yourself
the other important property is
important see their ability to
differentiate into virtually all types
of somatic cells and germ cells that
exist in the body and it turned out that
not one is a sensor for potency when I
generated not one no called ESL's then
can proliferate normally but they can no
longer differentiate so that one is
essential for potency this unexpected
results again brought me changed my
project from cancer to stem cells to ES
cells but again when I was working on
that one when I was working on that one
deficient ESL's I had to go back to
Japan and I suffered from a disease
which I designated dat well you may
wonder what it is ple actually I coined
the word PID stands for post America
depression
so you know I had such a great time in
San Francisco at Gladstone in many ways
after coming back to Japan I was
depressed I was very badly depressed
that I was about to could quit from
science but very luckily two events
happened in my life that rescued me from
PID the first event was the generation
of human ear cells by dr. Jamie Thompson
in Wisconsin before his success we only
had mouse embryonic stem cells I was
just using mouse embryonic stem cells I
was often told by my colleagues here
that Mouse cells may be interesting that
uses something more related to human
disease human medicine so that was one
reason for my PhD but because of his
success it turned out that ear cells are
very related to human medicine because
human ear cells have the to share the
two important properties with Mouse ear
cells we can expand human ear cells as
much as we want and then we can make
various types of human somatic cells
from human ear cells such as open edge
of neuron neural stem cells cardiac
cells and so on then we should use these
human cells to treat patients suffering
from various diseases and injuries such
as Parkinson disease and spinal cord
injuries and so on so again
it turned out that ESL's themselves
could help patients not loss patients
but human patients so when I first read
the science paper by dr. Jamie Thompson
I I got so excited I still remember that
moment the second event which rescues Me
from PFD was my promotion to Nara in
1999 I became a principal investigator
in another Institute of Science and
Technology so I had my own laboratory
for the first time when I was 37 years
old as you can see here this Institute
has a beautiful campus they have many
good faculty members they have many good
equipments they have many not many but
some technicians who can help me with my
mice and are the most importantly they
have many talented graduate students so
because of these two events I was able
to recover overcome my PID and I was
able to continue my science because I
got my own laboratory for the first time
I thought I should make a clear vision
or a long-term goal or my own laboratory
and I made this as the long-term goal or
vision of my lab I want to make years
like stem cells not from embryos but
from somatic cells from patient's own
cells by doing this we should be able to
overcome the moral eschol harder of
human yourselves because we have to use
human embryos
to generate human yourself many people
are against the usage of human ES cells
against the generation of human
yourselves and the usage of human ES
cells but if we can make years life
cells from adult patients on somatic
cells we can avoid this harder Mauro
huddle I thought at least in theory we
can do this we can convert without cells
back into the embryonic state because of
two scientific findings reported by
previous researchers to scientific
strings established by previous
researchers the vast scientific stream
plus is of course nuclear reprogramming
studied by Sir John garden as you heard
from in stock
sajin garden clearly demonstrated that
somatic cells can be reprogrammed back
into the embryonic state the other
scientific stream this factor mediated
self a conversion which was initiated by
dr. Harold Winthrop who showed that a
single transcription factor my OD can
convert fibroblasts into muscles in mice
so because of these two scientific
strings I thought there should be
factors that can reprogram somatic cells
back into the embryonic state by
identifying such reprogramming factors
we should we should be able to make ears
like sim cells directly from so much
however I had no idea how many factors
were required it could be just one it
could be ten it could be 100 or even
more so I had no idea how long it would
take to identify these reprogramming
factors it could take ten years twenty
years thirty years or even longer but
they luckily it didn't take that wrong
it took us six years before we
identified these four factors in 2006 we
were able to report this finding by
introducing the combination of only full
transcription factors or three ball
socks to Simek and k4 into Mouse skin
fibroblasts we can actually convert
somatic cells into es like stem cells
which I designated induced pluripotent
stem cells iPS cells in the following
the year 2007 2007 we and others have
shown that the same factor combination
can make human iPS cells so I want to
use just one slide to show you how we
identified those four four factors first
we collected 24 candidate factors with a
great help of my students and
technicians among them
is three members of my laboratory data
essential work we also established a
simple and sensitive estate system to
evaluate is 24 candidate factors to
members of my lab yozma talk Sabha and
Tomoko saga did this work actually we
generated a knockout mice and knockout
ESL's aubergine which I thought the
sensor in Mouse ESL's and in mass re
development however nothing happened to
those knockout mice and knockout ESL's
North wise knockout mice were just happy
knockout ESL's were just happy only my
student your see me began happy
but that but it turns out these mas
provided us a very useful system as a
system to evaluate these 24 candidates
so this is another reason we should
never give up then by using this simple
estate system very sensitive as a system
another member of my lab Casa Takahashi
he did animatable job to identify the
four factors out of the 24 so it was in
the days three young researchers who
generated IPS cells
Yosemite oxal and Kostas takahashi well
my very first graduate students Tomoko
Sokka was it my first technician without
devoted work done by these three we
could have never generated IPS cells at
least in my own laboratory so I'm very
very grateful to these young researchers
so finally I'd like to discuss about
potential or IPS cells there are two
major medical and pharmaceutical
applications of IPS cells
the first one is pharmaceutical
applications by generating IPS cells
from patients we should be able to
develop disease models then we can
perform drug screening so this is a
pharmaceutical in vitro application of
IPS cells
the other application is in vivo
vacation is cell therapy or the
regenerative medicine so let me first
discuss about pharmaceutical application
of IPS cells by using motor neuron
disease as you know motor neuron is a
specific type of nerve that transmits
the signal from the brain to other
muscles in these patients suffering from
motor neuron disease there are motor
neurons get degenerated and eventually
done so they will become unable to move
they cannot use the muscles however they
can still think they can still see they
can hear that they become unable to move
and in the end they become unable to
breathe so it's a very very sad
situation for patients and for their
family members despite numerous efforts
by numerous scientists we still don't
have effective drugs
what is patients suffering from water
neuron disease primarily because we
don't have a good disease model to
perform drug screening for many diseases
we have animal models by which we can
make we can perform drug screening and
by which we have identified many drugs
which are effective on both animal
models and on human patients
we do have mouse models for motor neuron
disease like ALS many drugs have been
developed using
the animal models many drugs have fun to
be effective home nice but very sadly
all of those medicine drugs
turned out to be not effective on human
patients
so for motor neuron disease for people
we do have to use human cells to perform
drug screening however it is impossible
to obtain sufficient amount of motor
neurons from patients by biopsy to
perform drug screening so that has been
the limitation but now with this
technology IPS cell technology many
researchers all over the places in the
world they have been generating IPS
cells from patients suffering from motor
neuron diseases and other intractable
diseases then they have succeeded in
making a large amount of motor neurons
having the same genetic information with
patients then now we have an opportunity
to generate disease models using
patients on motor neurons and we now
have a great opportunity to perform drug
screening using patient's own cells one
of my colleagues in Kyoto dr. Han Giza
you know where he has generated IPS
cells from both patients like errors and
other motor neuron diseases as well as
healthy control individuals as you know
motor neurons and other neurons have
these kinds of projections that Nesser
for signal translate signal or or
transaction from brain to muscles doctor
I know
have shown that motor neurons from
patients have significantly shorter
projections than control motor neurons
so we are now using this phenotype to
perform drug screening we have to screen
thousands of drug candidates so we have
been using this kind of robotics system
to identify drug candidates for patients
suffering from motor neuron disease and
other intractable diseases let me move
on to the other application namely cell
therapy or also known as regenerative
medicine so just like human in your
cells we can expand the number of human
iPS cells as much as we want then we can
make a large amount of various types of
human cells from IPS cells including
dopaminergic neurons retinal cells
cardiac cells neural progenitor cells
bright red then we should be able to use
these cells to treat patients suffering
from Parkinson disease macular
degeneration cardiac failure spinal cord
injury and preterite efficiency in Japan
and in some other countries researchers
are conducting preclinical studies to
prove the efficacy and safe Ness of
these IPS cell mediated cell therapy
next Monday December 10th I'm going to
receive the Nobel Prize when we have for
many researchers scientists who have
contributed to the generation of IPS
cells and who have contributed to the
very rapid progress of this technology
as I described IPS cells became possible
with the three free existing scientific
streams the first stream has nuclear
reprogramming again it was initiated by
dr. Gordon Sir John Gurdon then dr. sir
young women succeeded in somatic
groaning in mammals in sheep for the
first time in 1997 in 2001 dr. Tucker's
tada demonstrated that Mouse ES cells
have reprogramming factors so this dream
scientific stream was essential for me
to initiate the other work the second
important stream is again factor
mediated cell rate conversion initiated
by dr. wine fraud who unfortunately
passed away when he was still very young
the third essential stream is ESL's
embryonic stem cells initiate initiated
by Sir Martin Evans in 1981 dr. Austin
Smith and others have been identifying
many factors that play important laws
them very potency including all three
for so
in 1998 Jamie comes dr. Thompson
succeeded in generating human embryonic
stem cells so all of these works was
sensor were indispensable for the
generation of like yourselves now from
IPS cells
new scientific streams have already
announced in 2007 dr. love yes provided
the first proof of concept of IPS cell
based cell therapy in mouse models in
2009 dr. George Daley
and dr. Kevin Egan generated IPS cells
from patients for the last time I have
to mention here that there is another
string which has emerged from IPS cells
in 2008 dr. Douglas Melton showed that
cell fates can be directly converted in
people in during mice by introducing
just a small number of transcription
factors this method is now called direct
reprogramming which have been which has
been followed by many researchers more
recently in 2012 this year dr. Deepak
Shri bustable provided the first proof
of concept of therapy based on direct
reprogramming in mice so I really hope
that in the very near future these
technologies will help patients either
in cell therapy
or in drug discovery I also hope that
some of these researchers will visit
another Nobel Prize for their works in
the near future so finally I am going to
thank many of my colleagues of my
parents in two places one the first
place is in code Center for IPS cell
research and application established two
years ago we now have more than 250
people working in this building and
grateful to all of them for their hard
work I am also grateful to coat
University for their continuous support
to our Institute and to our science our
president dr. Hughes Matsumoto is with
us today let me also thank to Gladstone
Institute in San Francisco since 2007 I
have a small group in addition to Kyoto
at Gladstone in San Francisco
compared to Kyoto it's a very small
group but they are all talented
brilliant and independent people so oh I
visit Gladstone almost every four or
five or six weeks my bigger visit to San
Francisco till Gladstone always
activates my science so I would like to
thank dr. Bob maybe and also dr. Deepak
Srivastava who are also with us today
for this great opportunity finally also
with me today are my family member
I have my wife my mother-in-law my
daughter's my brother-in-law my sister
well my own mother is in Stockholm but
she cannot make to this hole today
well she said see your English is
terrible so I won't understand
well as as you know science being the
scientist is full Joy's but at the same
time it's rope stress so without
continuous support from my family I
could have never been here today so I'm
very very grateful to my family well I
miss my father who passed away 25 years
ago and my father-in-law who passed away
earlier this year I hope my group they
are enjoying this moment together
somewhere well it was my father who
talked me into medicine and it was my
father-in-law who showed me how a doctor
should be my father-in-law was a doctor
for a long time so I really wanted I
really need need to bring our technology
IPS cell technology until drinks into
patients I really have to do that before
I meet both of my fathers in the field
in the near future so thank you very
much for your kind attention to some
talk
before concluding the novella lectures
for 2012 I would now like to ask both
the Nobel laureates to step forward
please please dr. Gordon I am
wait where do we have the promenade oh
there you are
and a big hat
well thank you very much for those
outstanding lectures and now can I ask
everybody to take your seats
because I would like you to stay in your
seats and let our honored guests leave
first and thereafter everybody can leave
so thank you very much for for your
cooperation here so let us have the
guests of honors leaving first and then
the rest of us can leave thank you very
much
you